una película de pompa seducción y juegos
de poder inauguró el festival de cannes
[Música]
levantó el telón por todo lo alto
proyectando una película anclada en la
historia de Francia yana ibagué de
mayween narra la verdadera historia de
una Cenicienta Una chica sin títulos ni
Gloria que terminó siendo la favorita
del Rey Luis 15
[Música]
fue escrita dirigida y protagonizada por
la francesa mayween ella Encarna a Jean
una prostituta bella y culta ofrecida
para divertir al rey de Francia Luis
quince termina enamorándose perdidamente
de esta chica haciéndola su favorita lo
que suscita un terremoto de envidia y de
odio en la corrupción
fue filmada en el suntuoso Palacio de
Versalles y cuenta con un actor de lujo
el estadounidense Johnny Depp quien
después de protagonizar uno de los
juicios más escabrosos y mediáticos de
los últimos años contra su ex esposa
regresa al cine como un rey no sin
despertar cierta polémica en Calles
[Música]
se proyectó fuera de la competencia
inaugurando el festival de cannes 2023
[Música]